when you were in high school were you
known as the kid who could write music
and sing you were i was the musical i
think at 12 you started performing with
your father and what your uncle and some
people what you were like in a little
family a family band and who were your
influences when you're sitting down at
12 to write a song just your dad or are
you listening my dad would play really
good music i was blessed with that and
my mom and they would play like stevie
wonder and i would sit on the piano and
try to learn the horn parts for sir duke
right and even though how old are you
what 23 i'm 22. 22. if you're 22 years
old you've had a lot of performing under
your belt yeah like my dad
kind of just pushes me out there and
goes sing do you think it was important
to your parents that you become a star
uh i don't think it was important uh
they were always a fan of mine and they
didn't really know like
is she actually really good and they
just loved me they thought they loved me
until i got my publishing deal they're
like oh we were right well talk about
that you you so while you're in high
school you start writing songs and you
go to like a lot of songwriting
competitions yeah like what are these
competitions they stick you in a room
with a bunch of other kids awful it's
tragic but i would complain to my mom
like you guys don't love me you're not
helping me be a pop star like i need a
tour bus and they're like calm down and
they're like well let's go online and
put your songs in competitions and they
would bring me all over places like
colorado and long island to these
songwriting contests where like ages
from 16 to 50 year olds would hand in
their songs and then a table of people
would judge i had to walk in the room
and hand my cd and have them play it on
a little shitty speaker that just
sounded awful and i would write at the
top
bt dubs by the way i produce this so
don't judge the production i'm 16. how
would you produce your own songs with
all of the technology yeah you can do it
right my dad he wasn't a producer but he
knew he would research for me he was
like all right i heard that macintosh is
back and they have garageband you could
start here and then we'll upgrade so for
my christmas it would be like you have
logic and my brothers would get like
video games so what would you do would
you take uh an apple computer would you
get something like garageband and
garageband enables you to play every
instrument and to mix multi-track stuff
right so that's what you would do in
your room but you would have to know as
a musician like what the bass line
should sound like right and that's stuff
where my father would sit behind me for
years and he would do the bass for me
until finally one year i was like i got
it dad i know what it should sound like
so your training from a very young age
in a sense is your father's there is
your mentor you're sitting in your room
you're playing every instrument you're
listening to the masters like stevie
wonder and then you're writing your own
songs yes and do people start to
recognize you as a great songwriter
besides your father i mean do do do you
win these competitions yeah i remember
going back to that songwriting
competition durango in colorado and
everyone recognized me as the girl that
had that ukulele song and they would say
like this is your year you're gonna get
signed this year